hi this is um
going to be in broken down into several
different films because I don't want to
bore you with a long one
but it's for the members
all the members of the organization
t-i-a-e
takamusu iwama Aikido Europe
that I'm now currently the head of Soul
head of
and
recently I've been sending out a letter
asking people's opinions
on the way forward
it's brought in a response and these
films are
my way of
being in touch with everybody to let you
know
how I say the decision that I've made
that will be told to you
in the uh ongoing films
I'd like to just briefly tell those who
haven't got my book and
my history really
you may find it boring you may know it
but I'd like to just pass it through
I didn't take on the art of Aikido
willingly
it was done because I was a young motor
mechanic and I was working for myself
and a small wooden shed and it held a
mini and a half
on half of the mini was
outside in all the weathers and if I
needed to work on the front half then I
was okay if I had to work on the back
half obviously I'd turn the car around
the floor didn't last long it was a
wooden floor this in this lean-to shed
and it soon gave way after a lot of use
of jacking up and just being rotten so
the floor became really just a cinder
dirt
floor
and I would lay on this
but uh I was young
and at the age of
I was working for myself in this place
and um outside the a van broke down on
the main road and I was part of a main
garage I I rented this Shed off the the
main garage
that done their mots and other various
repairs and it had several mechanics in
there
this particular day they couldn't see to
the person and they sent them to me and
I went down there and it was just a
normal painter and decorator working for
someone he didn't have any money but he
said that his boss would come round and
pay me later
so I got him going to fix the problem
and it's strange
it's almost 50 years since I started
Aikido this September coming in 2023
will be 50 years
will be the month I started
I fixed the van and I still remember to
this day the they had an electronic old
point system where these things used to
open and close causing a spark for the
engine to run and they'd they'd become
closed up and it stopped
how can I go about 50 years and remember
this small detail
some things are important to remember
and some things are not and that's what
I want to talk about today
I've purposely put myself in this room
in our house to show you the picture on
the back in the background
hate is a bad word isn't it and I don't
think I hate anybody or anything
but I really dislike this picture
and yet my Jane she loves it is one of
her we've got about around about 100
pictures dotted around the house in all
sizes
this is one of her favorites
and the whole point is if you can see in
the background it says pain
made in pain
they've painted out the s
it's up to you whether you've seen this
picture or not
before not and it doesn't really matter
to me what does matter to me
is the point I want to make
I love her dearly and
I put up with the pictures that she
likes that I don't like
it's not that I don't look at them but I
look at them and I wonder why anybody
would want a picture like that
rather than a pleasant scenery or even
you know two lovers
painted
in a in a nice grip you know romantic
one or a scenery
for you or something that brings
happiness rather than
this what I consider violent picture
you see the world is full of good and
bad and we have to put up with it
and
aikido's no different
I recently heard from a student around
the world
that
this year
and the
um there's normally around about 23 to
25 Russian
senior black belt students
attend a particular seminar
in Europe
and this year because of the war in
Ukraine they're not able to attend
well we know the reasons why they can't
attend but what
made me
stand back and it didn't phase the
person telling me but it has really
quite affected myself
they said that these blackboat teachers
who at least can't come but can have
contact
they found that almost all of them were
in agreement with the war
in the Ukraine
for me this is not
what Aikido should be telling you this
is not what Sensei said oh since you
changed his art I after the second World
War
this is by the way not
a war or who sides wins it's about our
organization in Europe
but I just want to clarify those sense
he changed his heart after the second
world war because he wanted to make it
joyful
and he wanted it to bring love and
harmony to the Japanese people
at the time he didn't talk about the
world that that grew when the hombu dojo
in Tokyo
and was created and his son kishimura
Hiroshima
started teaching there and made and made
it into like a worldwide Enterprise
and Aikido hopefully was spread out
through the world bringing people
together in love and harmony
so our sense his hopes and wishes would
get out but
um
so so I find this very disturbing
and I'm sure it's not just the Russian
uh the senses the black belts and that
who feel that it's right to kill others
but what a disgraceful thing when
I've spent all this time trying to hone
my personal self become a better person
and not the person I used to be
egotistic
and
only thinking of myself
oh senses Aikido has done this and
helped me become a better person
I've had more Hobbies than most of you
listening to me
and it's not but it will sound like ego
ego me me me throughout these films
but what I'm going to try and explain to
you is
are we doing our senses art as he hoped
or have we changed it to the point where
it's creating a bigger ego than ever
just because we can dominate we can
control people if we're a teacher we run
a club and we are the boss of those
students
what
upon you know many teachers they think
they own the students it's a little bit
like I should want you to own Ukraine
to bring it back into the fold
people are insignificant Killers many as
you like
this is not our sense his heart
anyhow I'm I'm diverting but I want you
to realize that we're all different
every one of you listening to me now
will have different views on Aikido
your techniques will look different to
onlookers they will be the same
techniques as we're all doing but they
will look different
one of my senior students said
that
when they came to a seminar
with over 200 attendees on the site her
seminar
since he asked us to stack Powers up to
Tammy together so that we were about
two feet higher let's say half a meter
higher
than the rest of the tatami and it was
against the wall
and he made there was three of us I
believe but we've all seen as we were
all top students of cytosensei
and we were all having to do the 31 Joe
Carter in time with each other
we couldn't see each other but because
of the years of training we pretty much
know the time and we have to do it
his statement was
I looked at all three of you one by one
and not one of you looked the same
why is that
I was quite taken back by this because I
would expect to be looking exactly the
same
as these two people are trying not to
make names even though names are coming
into my head I try not to say names
throughout the films
but there
yeah one's a seventh down now one was a
fifth then I was a fifth Dan
I think they were over sixth ahead of
the time the other person anyhow the the
point is
it's because we are individuals
the form is the same the skis would have
been the same
the whole 31 count Carter would have
been a 31 count Carter
if someone was just watching one of us
you imagine how Santa's sense he looks
at 250 people during the 31 count Carter
there'll be 250
251 however many that is different 31
count Carters because we are individuals
and you are an individual you must make
your own decisions in life however hard
they are
you'll have to put up with things that
you don't like
and not just accept the things you do
like
thank you for listening
the next film will come along show